fabrice epelboin professeur à sciences
po spécialiste des médias
bonsoir fabrice epelboin merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
ce feu vert de la cnil doit-on s'en
inquiéter
c'est pas tant le début d'une soucier de
la surveillance un snood n c'était en
elle est installée la soute et de la
surveillance il ya même pas six mois
cedrico nous proposer le lancement d'
alice m pour installer la reconnaissance
faciale et ils expérimentent et à large
échelle
et puis très rapidement on s'est aperçu
qu'en fait ces expérimentations avaient
lieu depuis déjà de nombreuses années la
société de surveillance
elle est là elle est là elle est de plus
en plus visible et surtout les gens en
sont de plus en plus conscients là on a
un beau chapitre qui est le pendant
occidental du contrôle social chinois en
chine selon ce que vous faites dans
l'espace public et la façon d'y être
surveillés analysés
vous avez plus ou moins de liberté et
bien c'est un tout premier pas vers ce
genre de système on a même pu un député
de la sarthe je crois de la rubrique en
marche qui proposait assez d'ego dans
une lettre dans une lettre ouverte de
courts délais certaine liberté de
déplacement avec l'utilisation
d'applications stop loving où on est
évidemment dans une bien moindre mesure
dans le même système que le contrôle
social chinois donc c'est la seconde
étape de la société de surveillance mais
il insiste elle est là c'est fait
c'est en place et c'est irréversible
alors la cnil a le grand gendarme de nos
libertés estime que l'application
respecte les différentes j'ai aussi des
dispositions législatives relatives à la
protection de la vie privée
vous n'y croyez pas fabrice epelboin
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu une évolution
de la cnil
la cnil est passé du gendarme qu'elle a
été il ya bien longtemps qu'il est là
pour faire appliquer la loi et s'assurer
qu'elle est respecté à quelque part le
même type de service que vous avez face
à un avocat fiscaliste qui va vous aider
à contourner la loi et vert avec la loi
pas nécessairement tricher avec la loi
mais que la contour des s'adapter faire
avec
c'est très précisément l'attitude qu'a
eue la cnil vis-à-vis l'ust projet stop
go vide dans cette affaire c'est une
évolution ali notable est allé sans
doute là pour durer
là il s'agit évidemment d'une question
de santé publique il ya certainement
pleins de citoyens français qui dirait
bah écoutez moi je veux bien donner un
petit peu de ma vie privée voile a
révélé que j'ai eus qu'ovide ont pas
révélé qu'il a autour de moi pour
peut-être plus aussi de liberté
notamment dans le déconfinement est ce
que ça vous paraît incroyable de penser
ça et vous tenez ces français là les
mettre en garde
moi je les mets en garde depuis plus de
10 ans sur ces sujets là je pense que
les français ne sont pas des enfants un
moment ou un autre ils vont réaliser ce
qui est en train de se passer encore une
fois edouard slow dance et 2013
rien n'a changé depuis vous imaginez
bien que bien au contraire on est de
plus en plus dans cette soucier de la
surveillance il ya ce gouvernement nous
annoncer la reconnaissance faciale dans
la rue il ya quelques mois aujourd'hui
c'est stop qu'ovide avec des
applications de racing et qui sont
censés être temporaire mais personne
n'en sait rien en réalité un vigipirate
était censé être temporaire la réalité
c'est qu'on entre dans petit à petit
cette société qui est construite depuis
dix ans un les programmes de
surveillance de base français
ils datent pas d'hier donc cesser c'est
juste un long chemin et c'est une étape
importante dans ce long chemin une autre
forme de société qu'est ce qu'on risque
au contraire en expliquer le risque
majeur n'est pas là très honnêtement ce
top cow vie d'un c'est un peu l'arbre
qui cache la forêt on a vu un
gouvernement se saisir tout d'un coup de
la souveraineté numérique était un
concept qui lui était totalement
étranger encore hier et en parallèle
fournir toutes les données de santé à
microsoft à travers le dada health club
up qui est le répertoire central de
toutes les données de santé dépensé bas
tout ça on le suit la microsoft
alors qu'en parallèle on refuse un
partenariat avec apple qui aurait permis
justement non pas de faire reposer cette
vie privée sur le gouvernement français
qui a pas vraiment un trac récolte mais
sur apple et google ce qui sont
malheureusement c'est terrible à dire un
moindre mal alors l'allemagne au cla a
reculé sur la centralisation des données
est ce que clairement la france va se
retrouver un petit peu
isolé l'allemagne n'a pas du tout la
même histoire que nous l'allemagne se
rappelle de façon très présent de la
stasi
l'allemagne se rappelle de ce qu'est la
surveillance et de son impact sur une
population et un climat politique et
c'est dans les mémoires chez nous en
france il faut remonter à vichy pour
avoir des services d'état qui surveille
de façon éhontée
toutes les communications d'aider des
citoyens les allemandes ça vraiment très
à coeur et de tout le temps ils se sont
opposés à la surveillance et ça date pas
d'hier
ils ont forcément ils vont prendre une
autre direction que nous ça c'est
certain
la france prend une direction très
particulière mais qui est on est plus ne
sera pas les seuls à prendre la
direction
il est évident que les allemands pendant
une autre direction fabrice epelboin
deux dernières questions ce procédé a
été testé par l'armée un pour justement
avoir sauvé rhône ont d'ailleurs de la
cnil c'était étonnant de tester ce genre
d'applications sur l'armée non les
militaires sont très en pointe sur tout
un tas de technologies internet
extrêmement pointus ça paraît pas
complètement fou qu'on puisse y tester
des des composants je doute que les
militaires aient pris part à la la
réalisation stop kovy d'un visiblement
ça plutôt été confiée par un entourage
ou à dire amicale de deux ministres et
secrétaires d'état au numérique mais
c'est pas aberrant de faire tester ça
dans des milieux militaires on y trouve
les gens extrêmement compétents et une
dernière petite question pour revenir
sur ce qu'on disait avant ces données
qui pourraient être gardées retenu
transférer cedrico à lui garantit
qu'elles seront effacées dans les six
mois
quelles preuves peut avoir le citoyen
aucune
le concept même d'effacer ce dans
l'univers du numérique et quelque chose
d'un peu suranné salle effacer quelque
chose peut prendre plusieurs réalités
dans le monde du numérique et selon la
réalité qu'on va lui donner on va ou non
ils fassent des choses par ailleurs dans
le monde du numérique nous passons tant
à transférer des données et transférer
des données c'est faire une succession
copie avec les sites à maternelle donc
ce ce terme d' effacer
a pas vraiment de réalité dans le
numérique et du coup le discours qu'on
peut tenir avec ce terme ne correspond à
rien de bien précis dont le numérique
pourrait tout à fait honnête
merci fabrice epelboin d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france